so here's my theory
he does not survive that initial test
flight he dies in that test flight you
can't push it to think he dies and then
it's he goes back to his old school
where his Nemesis is inferior is ailing
and like he needs to go and show him
love because he's now on the
unthreatened top dog his biggest flaw is
that he cares too much
this is and the girl and the the thing
and these boats he's on a boat he's
sailing he's like he's got another
motorcycle he's got a motorcycle with no
helmet he's like who's allowing that
and by the way they need me for a
mission where drones don't work that's
why they need they need me in the canyon
just like Star Wars to fly it don't say
just like Star Wars but it is that's
Maverick's favorite movie
that's why this is happening to fly
through the canyon to drop the bomb
exactly like Star Wars
unnamed unnamed country with an unnamed
threat
wow